the World Series is tonight and Game one
between the Los Angeles Dodgers and the
Houston Astros at Dodger Stadium this is
big deal it's very exciting
oh I think it's incredibly cool that Los
Angeles is hosting the World Series
someone in the audience someone in the
audience is clearing your throat very
definitely a distraction sir could you
please stop that oh I'm sorry but did
you say that the Los Angeles is hosting
the World Series yes I did that's that's
what I said that's right
so these Dodgers and Astros are the two
best baseball teams in the whole world
well yeah maybe I don't know world
series is just the name of the
tournament okay I mean all the teams are
from the United States
well there's one from Canada uh-huh so
maybe a better name for this baseball
tournament of yours should be a bunch of
teams from the United States and one
from Canada series I'm sorry who the
hell are you are you talking to me yes
I'm Todd oh okay yes that's what
happened to you that's what I thought
hello my name is Francisco googly Oni
and I would like to officially enter my
country's baseball team into the World
Series
okay and what country is that Bolivar a
believer boy I've never heard of that
yes it's a teeny country in between
Bolivia and Paraguay and I want my
country's team to compete against the
Dodgers and Astros that way it will
truly be a World Series okay listen I
don't care how you pronounce world it's
not
it's not gonna happen but we've a great
baseball team and I'll star at every
position okay that's great who cares you
know everything fine I will list them
all for you now please do not list at
first paddle we've got Enrique pizazz
that second Squasher we've got tiny huge
Schwartz at Short sandwich we've got
sting but not that sting at long
sandwich we've got berry tomato at left
bikini skier it's none other than Tammy
zing bats at center scrambler it's that
kid who's always at the library for some
reason
[Applause]
he gets around yes he does yeah
a cheeseball throwing machine we've got
Emily the cheeseball throwing machine
and that moose
we've got Clyde the moose and there you
have it the future world champion wait a
minute wait a minute in no way did that
resemble a baseball team which is
doesn't look like a baseball team
yes well the rules for a baseball are a
little different in Bulova way okay god
I'm gonna regret this but what are the
rules of believe aquaian baseball oh yes
well we play three games per inning two
innings per day one day per season and
four seasons per inning at the top of
every other inning the cheese ball
throwing machine throws a cheese ball at
the opposing teams long sandwich who has
to hit the cheese bow to the bikini
skier if the bikini skier can get the
cheese ball to the scrambler without
getting hurt by the Moose yasiel puig
punches disc washer really the key to
the whole game is avoiding the moon oh
for God's sake no darling her again
familiar yes I have to ask one more
question I would write this - why do you
have so many metals ah well in bulimic
way you get a medal for every bowel
movement oh no oh no what's wrong
Oh God No
[Music]
thank you
you should go you to get out
see you at the World Series Conan okay
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
you